D’habitude, pour les
périodes anciennes comme celle dont on va
parler, les historiens n’ont pas de date
à se mettre sous la dent.
Les évolutions sont lentes et floues, les
périodes, délimitées à la louche.
Il existe cependant une exception, c’est
la fin de l’âge du Bronze.
Dans les années 1180 avant J.-C., la quasi-totalité
des grandes cités de Méditerranée orientale
s’effondre subitement sous les coups d’envahisseurs
mystérieux.
Le monde grec, l’empire hittite en Turquie
actuelle ainsi que la côte du Proche-Orient
alors sous domination égyptienne en font
les frais.
Les palais brûlent, les cités se vident
de leurs habitants et des civilisations disparaissent.
C’est la fin brutale d’une époque flamboyante,
la fin de l’âge du Bronze.
Cet épisode a durablement changé le destin
de la région, modifiant les équilibres démographiques,
rayant de la carte de brillantes civilisations
et dopant le développement d’autres cultures
pour des siècles à venir.
Tout ça à cause d’une invasion.
En tout cas, c’est ce qu’on a longtemps
pensé.
La réalité historique est, on va le voir,
plus complexe.
Le seul empire de Méditerranée orientale
qui ait survécu à ce cataclysme est l’Egypte,
superpuissance centrée sur le Nil et sa vallée
à l’insolente fertilité.
Plus peuplée, mieux organisée et peut-être
plus chanceuse, l’Egypte parvient à stopper
cette mystérieuse invasion en 1177 avant
J.-C. dans le delta du Nil où les envahisseurs
avaient débarqué.
Ce sont donc les Egyptiens, par le biais d’inscriptions
célébrant cette victoire, qui nomment les
responsables de cette invasion :
les Peleset, Tjeker, Aqayawa, Shekelesh, Shardane,
Denyen et Weshesh.
Des noms obscurs que les archéologues ont
regroupés sous l’appellation de « Peuples
de la mer ». Reste à savoir qui ils étaient
réellement.
Malgré quelques représentations de prisonniers
capturés lors de la bataille, en particulier
sur le temple de Ramsès III à Médinet Habou
(icono), l’origine de ces peuples reste
incertaine.
Aucun site archéologique connu ne peut faire
office de point de départ de cette invasion.
Pour avoir une idée de leur origine, historiens
et archéologues se sont donc attachés à
remonter la piste des destructions, dans l’espoir
d’obtenir une chronologie et de retracer
ainsi le trajet de ces envahisseurs.
Et à première vue, il faut avouer que le
palmarès des « Peuples de la mer » est
plutôt impressionnant.
Mycènes, Pylos, Thèbes, Troie, Milet, Hattusa
capitale de l’empire hittite, Tarse, la
riche cité côtière d’Ugarit, Ashdod,
Chypre et la côte de Palestine (carte).
Toutes ces cités et régions ont été dévastées
dans les années 1190-1180 avant J.-C.
Malheureusement, la chronologie ne permet
pas de reconstituer un mouvement uniforme
d’ouest en est.
Dater des niveaux de destructions s’avère
assez compliqué pour ces périodes, surtout
si l’on veut les dater à l’année près.
Par ailleurs, ces « Peuples de la mer » ne
sortent pas de nulle part.
Les Égyptiens aux siècles précédents,
les accusaient de faits de piraterie.
Ils n’ont donc pas fait irruption brutalement
en Méditerranée orientale, puisqu’ils
fréquentaient déjà ses côtes, mais ils
ont en revanche montré beaucoup plus de férocité
en ce début de XIIe siècle avant notre ère,
au point d’être accusés de détruire des
cités entières.
Mis à part les reliefs égyptiens du temple
de Ramsès III, il y a d’autres documents
écrits qui témoignent de cette invasion.
Il s’agit de lettres échangées par les
souverains d’Ugarit et d’Alashiya, sans
doute l’ancien nom de Chypre, pour coordonner
leur réponse militaire face aux envahisseurs.
Certains textes laissent penser qu’une partie
de la population locale s’est même alliée
aux nouveaux venus et s’est révoltée contre
le pouvoir en place.
Et j’en reparlerai tout à l’heure.
A part les destructions des villes, les archéologues
peuvent aussi deviner les épisodes d’invasions
grâce à l’apparition de nouveaux objets
et traditions sur les sites qu’ils fouillent.
Un changement rapide dans les manières de
construire ou de décorer les poteries indique
alors que la population a changé, ou au moins
que le pouvoir a été remplacé.
Et à cette époque, on constate justement
de nouvelles pratiques alimentaires et techniques
dans le travail du textile en Méditerranée
orientale, ce qui fait vraiment penser à
une vague de peuplement découlant d’invasions.
Certains de ces “Peuples de la mer” seraient
donc restés sur place.
D'ailleurs, parmi les peuples cités par les
Egyptiens figurent les Peleset, dont la sonorité
est très voisine de la Palestine et des Philistins.
Philistins qui sont évoqués notamment dans
les récits bibliques, puisqu’ils se sont
affrontés aux Hébreux par la suite.
On aurait donc là, un peuple installé durablement
après l’invasion, donnant même son nom
à la région qu’il colonise, la Palestine.
Ce n’est pas improbable, quand on pense
que la France tient elle aussi son nom d’envahisseurs
originaires de Germanie.
D’autres noms, eux, semblent nous renseigner
plutôt sur l’origine des envahisseurs,
et non pas sur leur point de chute.
Les Aqayawas évoquent les Achéens, autrement
dit les Grecs.
Les Shekelesh toujours en se fiant aux sonorités,
seraient à rapprocher des Siciliens et les
Shardanes, des habitants de la Sardaigne.
A en croire les noms cités par les Egyptiens,
on verrait donc se dessiner un mouvement important
de populations venues de l’ouest et déferlant
sur le monde oriental.
Mais si on y voit un peu plus clair quant
à leur origine, le motif de cette invasion
reste inconnu.
Des archéologues ont proposé de trouver
cette explication dans une sorte d’effet
boule de neige d’invasions.
Ce phénomène est connu pour le Moyen-âge
par exemple, les Huns ou les Mongols en déferlant
sur l’Asie et l’Europe ont poussé devant
eux d’autres peuples qui fuyaient les destructions
(et qui se mettent eux aussi à envahir d’autres
régions).
Or on trouve dans les mythes grecs sur les
« âges obscurs » des récits d’une invasion
dorienne c’est-à-dire en provenance du
nord de la Grèce continentale, les Balkans.
Pour certains chercheurs, on aurait donc peut-être
affaire à un mouvement d’invasion plus
profond, dont les “Peuples de la mer”
ne seraient finalement que l’aboutissement.
Cet effet boule de neige ne fournit malheureusement
pas une explication parfaite, notamment en
ce qui concerne la Sicile et la Sardaigne
ou encore pourquoi la population locale se
serait alliée aux envahisseurs.
Et puis d’ailleurs, pour l’instant, de
telles preuves d’une invasion venue du nord
de la Grèce sont introuvables.
Aucune nouveauté suffisamment brutale dans
la culture matérielle ne permet de conclure
qu’une population aurait déferlé avec
armes et bagages sur le monde grec ou anatolien
à la fin de l’âge du Bronze.
Il y a bien d’autres récits qui nous sont
parvenus de ces âges lointains… l’Iliade
et l’Odyssée.
Ils prennent justement place dans cette chronologie,
au XIIe siècle avant notre ère.
Mais s’ils décrivent la destruction de
la ville de Troie, qui on l’a vu, a bien
été ravagée par cette vague d’invasion,
ils restent malheureusement silencieux sur
le reste des événements.
On va donc explorer d’autres hypothèses
pour expliquer l’effondrement de la Méditerranée
orientale à la fin de l’âge du Bronze.
L’historien américain Eric Cline dans son
livre 1177 avant J.-C., Le jour où la civilisation
s’est effondrée, recense au moins quatre
autres causes majeures possibles.
Alors, il le fait en pas moins de 200 pages
extrêmement répétitives ou qui parlent
carrément d’autre chose, donc si ça vous
dérange pas, on va synthétiser un petit
peu...
Les tremblements de terre
Il semble en effet que la Grèce ait connu
entre 1225 et 1175 avant J.-C. une série
de séismes importants, que les archéologues
reconnaissent à des stigmates caractéristiques
de destruction.
Des murs et colonnes effondrés, ainsi que
des fissures sur de nombreux sites tels que
Mycènes, Tirynthe, Pylos ou Thèbes, semblent
indiquer une très forte activité sismique
à cette époque.
Toutefois, et malgré les dommages importants
qu’ils ont causés, ces tremblements de
terre ne peuvent pas expliquer à eux seuls
des migrations de grande ampleur et l’effondrement
de civilisations entières.
Un changement climatique
De nombreux chercheurs ont proposé qu’un
épisode de sécheresse en Méditerranée
orientale ait pu entraîner une famine et
motiver le départ de populations.
On dispose en effet de nombreux textes de
l’empire hittite, en Turquie actuelle, qui
demandent aux Egyptiens de leur envoyer leur
excédent de céréales.
Les hittites en manquaient régulièrement
et un épisode de sécheresse assez long aurait
pu transformer cette précarité alimentaire
en famine généralisée.
Les études sur les restes fossiles de pollen
piégés dans les sédiments de toute la région
confirment d’ailleurs un épisode de sécheresse
important aux dates qui nous intéressent.
Au point de pousser au départ des milliers
de personnes ? Difficile à dire.
Des révoltes intérieures
Les destructions constatées sur de nombreux
palais grecs et sur plusieurs sites du Proche-Orient
ont pu être causés par des révoltes des
habitants.
Plusieurs hypothèses ont été imaginées
à ce sujet, une trop grande pression fiscale,
des émeutes pour obtenir des vivres dans
un contexte de famine… Là encore, difficile
d’imaginer qu’une insurrection puisse
conduire à l’abandon pur et simple d’une
cité.
Une coupure des relations commerciales
Les cités en proie aux difficultés évoquées
jusqu’à maintenant auraient selon cette
théorie, davantage succombé à la rupture
des relations commerciales qui auraient suivi
les invasions et autres révoltes.
La Méditerranée orientale, il y a trois
mille ans, était un espace parcouru par de
nombreux navires marchands et les cités possédaient
des économies très interdépendantes.
La rupture d’approvisionnement notamment
en céréales et en produits de luxe comme
le bronze, aurait pu avoir des conséquences
tragiques sur les royaumes.
S’il y a bien eu une invasion des « Peuples
de la mer », on le voit, elle ne peut pas
porter seule la responsabilité de cet effondrement.
Toutes les causes que nous avons énumérées
ont pu se produire à plusieurs reprises au
IIe millénaire avant J.-C.
Les tremblements de terre, tout comme les
sécheresses et épisodes de famines étaient
fréquents, les révoltes, les guerres et
les crises économiques, nous le savons, même
aujourd’hui, se produisent régulièrement.
Pour autant, ils n’entraînent pas systématiquement
d’effondrement de civilisations.
Mais en 1180 avant J.-C., ces différents
événements ont probablement eu lieu tous
en même temps, ou presque.
L’historien Eric Cline parle pour caractériser
ce moment de perfect storm, expression anglaise
qu’on pourrait traduire par un « parfait
désastre », résultat d’une conjonction
d’accidents, qui, s’ils sont surmontables
individuellement, deviennent tous ensembles
un cataclysme dévastateur.
Comme souvent pour expliquer des phénomènes
complexes, on ne peut pas se contenter d’une
explication unique.
J’avais déjà évoqué pour parler de la
disparition des Mayas (lien vidéo), une conjugaison
de facteurs un peu similaires.
La fin de l’âge du Bronze en Méditerranée
orientale, c’est donc une sorte d’effet
domino, sans qu’il soit possible de définir
véritablement une cause première.
L’effondrement se serait propagé parce
que les royaumes étaient trop dépendants
les uns des autres.
Avec leur pouvoir très centralisé et des
circuits économiques extrêmement dépendants
des commandes royales, c’étaient en réalité
des constructions fragiles, et la chute a
pu être très rapide.
Parfaits bouc-émissaires, les « Peuples
de la mer » ne sont donc que la partie émergée
de ce “parfait désastre”, l’évènement
le plus visible pour les archéologues.
Mais on suppose désormais que leur invasion
n’a pas été aussi soudaine et violente
qu’on le disait.
Navigateurs présents depuis plusieurs siècles
dans la région, on pense aujourd’hui qu’ils
ont migré vers l’Est pendant plusieurs
décennies.
Fuyards, réfugiés climatiques, envahisseurs,
colons, peut-être tout en même temps.
Le mystère reste entier.